[Music]
hello there internet it's me john oliver
the big bird boy that goes chirper to
yak
we are off this week but uh we wanted to
give you a quick update because you may
remember a few months ago we did a story
about local car commercials specifically
the fact that it'd come to our attention
that some of them looked suspiciously
similar hey you know me scott elder here
from elder mitsubishi
i'm in a pickle my doctor told me to
turn it down a notch before my heart
explodes
scott lehman here from premier auto
center and i'm in a pickle my doctor
told me to calm down before my heart
explodes hey fred brody here from brody
automotive doctor told me i need to turn
it down a notch so my heart doesn't
explode steve johnson here from zumbrota
ford my doctor told me to turn it down a
notch so my heart doesn't explode
but dad your doctor told you to calm
down before your heart explodes i mean
excellent right every single pickle a
star and they made that look easy which
is impressive because if i may quote my
favorite pig
it's not easy being green you know
i believe it was sandy meisner that said
acting is behaving truthfully under
imaginary circumstances and the beauty
here is i truly believed every one of
those men was a pickle with a fatal
heart condition that could strike at the
drop of a scream but the fact that these
scripts seem to be recycled really
bothered me i'm not going to recap our
whole story right now but it turns out
there was one company writing scripts
for a whole bunch of dealerships which
seemed like a real shame because at
their best local car ads should be
unique and completely unhinged not
franchised out making nothing special
anymore and that is why we ended our
segment with what we felt was a
tantalizing offer
we've written a script and it's good
it's really good and we're offering it
to one and only one car dealership to
use in a commercial for free so long as
they agree to some simple terms the main
one being you have to agree to produce
this exactly as it is written and
you can't read it before you agree
yeah
we did do that and i would argue that
that was a hell of an offer on our part
and to be honest
quite a risk for someone to take on do
you really think we can be trusted with
a situation like that because i
definitely don't
and yet thankfully multiple dealerships
did end up contacting us and we
eventually chose one zombrota ford in
zumbrota minnesota and while you or they
might well have expected our script to
force them to do something big wild and
cartoonish like i don't know dressing as
a giant baby and making them slap their
baby butts while their customers go goo
gaga for savings i don't know we
actually went a different way the ad
that we wrote was a tense domestic
psychodrama that yes
was
incidentally about their car dealership
but it was mainly about a marriage in
serious trouble
the first lines in our script were an
individual staring out of a window and
saying
storm's coming any minute now
and their spouse responding i want a
divorce that is how
it began
so we were fascinated to see how they
handled our unflinching exploration of
domestic collapse and to their eternal
credit they threw themselves at the
source material so tonight
i am proud to unveil the ad that will be
airing in the zumbrota area this week
and add that no other dealership in
america will have so sit back
grab a tissue and please
enjoy
[Music]
storms come in any minute now
i want a divorce
you don't mean that
like you would even know what i mean you
don't know me you're right i don't
anymore and ever since we bought that
all-wheel drive minivan from zumbrota
ford you've changed maybe i have maybe i
changed the minute i put my hands on the
steering wheel of that new minivan
maybe in that moment i realized how
empty i feel inside i don't want the
minivan from zorota ford of course not
why would i we don't even have kids oh
here we go again with a kid thing what
happened to us we used to laugh we used
to dance
remember the lodge don't you dare bring
up the lodge you're impossible and you
take up too much space like our zumbrota
ford minivan that can barely fit in the
garage how many times do i have to say
it i wrote the dimensions down right but
the architect made the garage wrong it's
always the architect with you isn't it
kevin
i'm steve johnson of zumbrota ford and
i'm in a pickle couples therapy
shmupples therapy a new car is what you
want so come on down to zombrota ford
and see me steve johnson i'm a dealer
for the people
i mean come on
that is a plus
all due respect to oscar isaac and
jessica chastain but that is a
scene from a marriage right there
to me it's all the little touches that
we didn't specify in the script but
which they did anyway the choice to show
a fairly clear sky right before the line
storm's coming any minute now great
excellent
the cutaway to the big minivan in the
small garage very very good the couple's
therapy shmooples therapy graphics
engulfed by what appear to be dozens of
green coronaviruses genius and very
topical and finally the husband from the
ad walking into the dealership and away
from the wreckage of his relationship at
the end of the commercial that is
narrative closure mother
that's how you do it
tie up the ends
look
by congratulations and heartfelt thanks
to the people of zombrota ford we put
you in a pickle
and you did something that truly made me
feel like my heart was about to explode
thank you so much for watching we're
back october 24th good night
[Applause]